hey thoughty2 here the absent bomb
hydrogen bomb nuclear bomb whatever you
want to call it it is the single most
destructive thing humanity has ever
created one nuclear device could flatten
a city the size of London and the United
States of America has lost eight of them
permanently misplaced these estranged
nuclear warheads are called broken
Arrow's by the Department of Defense the
first was lost on February the 13th 1950
a b-36 bomber was flying from Alaska to
Texas it lost power and began to
freefall rapidly to prevent the bomb
from detonating when the plane crashed
the pilots dropped the payload a fat man
nuclear bomb into the Pacific Ocean
submarine search teams were despatched
to find it but it was never located and
to this day one of the world's most
powerful nuclear bombs remains
undetonated somewhere at the bottom of
the Pacific Ocean another two bombs of a
combined yield of 3.4 megatons went
missing 1956 when it b-47 latin florida
whilst traveling over the mediterranean
sea from thick fog
it went mythic it was never heard from
again the nuclear weapons were never
found
another went missing in a swamp another
bomb rolled off a US Navy vessel just
off the coast of Japan which Japan
weren't too pleased about to say the
least
and another two were lost at sea when a
u.s. submarine mysteriously sank along
with all ninety nine crew members but
whilst America has been busy losing
nuclear warheads for Russia were hard at
work building them at the height of the
Cold War in 1985 the Soviet Union had a
terrified 39,000 197 nuclear weapons
many more than the count of America's
peak stockpile
at 30 1139 it has often been said that
nuclear war is madness and math it is
mad as in mutually assured destruction
the only thing that has so far prevented
the end of the world
a doctrine of war that means if one side
uses their full nuclear arsenal on the
other side then the other side will
automatically use their nuclear arsenal
upon the attacker in response
therefore wiping out both countries and
probably the rest of the world it is
based on the Nash equilibrium which
dictates that when both opponents
possess the same strategy neither side
has anything to gain by using their
strategy and therefore the best course
of action is to do nothing and so the
world today is frozen in a constant
state of being on the brink of nearly
blowing each other off but how did it
come to this fleeing persecution and the
Nazi regime many Jewish scientists fled
to the west during the early days of the
war including highly influential
physicists such as Albert Einstein Hans
bethe Edward Teller and John von Neumann
most of them joined the Manhattan
Project a brand-new top-secret program
between United States United Kingdom and
Canada with one primary goal to invent
the atomic bomb the enormous project
employed 130,000 people in costing us
the modern-day equivalent of 25 billion
dollars just three years after the
project was established the u.s.
detonated the world's first ever nuclear
weapon in the New Mexico desert
it was codenamed Trinity and from then
on they didn't waste any time and just
three weeks later they detonated a
uranium bomb over her Russians killing
over 140,000 people in the bloody
aftermath of the war there was a
twilight struggle between the Communist
Soviet Union and capitalist America to
gain control of and
shape how the post-world War will look
Russia had also gone nuclear
and the arms race had begun an arms race
that would last 44 years
this was the Cold War it was the
ultimate contest of mind and each side
went to extraordinary lengths just to
prove they were the most endowed country
the USA seriously considered the plan to
a drop enormous condoms labeled medium
into the USSR to demoralize the Soviets
and give the impression that the
Americans had a greater manhood the u.s.
also developed a top-secret plan to
detonate a nuclear bomb on the moon as a
display of military prowess but it was a
tad too expensive and complicated so
when those plans didn't come to fruition
they created project acoustic Kitty the
CIA implanted microphones attached to a
radio transmitter inside cuts the plan
was to use cats to spy on the Kremlin
because nobody is going to suspect a cat
with a wire sticking out of it but
during the very first test the cat was
accidentally run over by a car so that
threw a spanner of doubt into the
general reliability of speical and the
acoustic Kitty program was scrapped but
tensions grew until it all came to a
climax during the most intense and
uncertain 13 days of the Cold War the
Cuban Missile Crisis
October the 60th 1962 Russia gets a bee
in its bonnet over ballistic missiles at
America had deployed in Italy and Turkey
conveniently an eerie read and pointed
right out to the USSR Russia responded
by placing a bunch of their nuclear
weapons in Cuba in frightfully close
proximity to the US giving Russia the
opportunity to destroy any number of
American cities with ease during these
nail-biting 13 days the world was closer
to complete nuclear annihilation than it
has ever been eventually an agreement
was reached between John F Kennedy
crucial that both parties were
dismantled and removed their respective
weapons from Italy Turkey and Cuba but
what few people know is that during the
Cuban Missile Crisis we came just a
hair's breadth from total nuclear
annihilation because a free man in a
submarine during the crisis Kennedy put
a blockade on all sea traffic to Cuba to
prevent Russia from delivering even more
nuclear weapons to the small island
nation but a Soviet submarine is hiding
deep in the Caribbean Sea around Cuba
u.s. Navy vessels pick it up on their
radars and start dropping depth charges
to the left and the right of the
submarine to try and deter it back to
Russia the sub is violently shaking the
onboard temperature rapidly rising a
decision had to be made quickly the sub
hadn't made contact with Russia has
several days they were too deep their
communications to reach the surface they
had no idea what was going on above the
water completely in the dark the three
Soviet submarine commanders on board the
vessel came to the conclusion that
full-scale nuclear war had erupted it
above the surface they thought that
World War II was underway hence the
aggression they were receiving little
did the Americans know that this
submarine was equipped with an enormous
nuclear torpedo capable of wiping out a
nearby fleet of the u.s. destroyers or
an entire city if they chose one of the
submarine captains proclaimed were going
to blast them now they readied the
nuclear torpedo and their hand was
hovering above the red button just
millimeters away if they had fired the
nuclear weapon it would have led to a
chain of events that would have actually
caused full-scale nuclear war and the
end of the world
but they didn't fire the nuclear Torpy
because of the calm temperament
of one man Vasily Alexandrovich
archetype Soviet submarines were only
allowed to fire their nuclear weapons if
all three onboard commanders agreed to
do so unanimously the other two
commanders had agreed to fire and were
putting vasily to acquiesce what you
would not he believed it was not an
attack with just a not-so-subtle way of
america telling them to get away from
cuba he remained calm and talked down
over to commanders saving the world
these freak instances aren't as rare as
you might hope in total there have been
14 events when nuclear weapons have very
nearly been launched due to accidents or
false alarms but why is nuclear war mad
why does mutual assured destruction have
to be the only way is it not possible
what America could use their full
nuclear force on Russia's nuclear
facilities in a pre-emptive strike
completely wiping Russia
off them up before they even have a
chance to retaliate or vice versa well
at the height of the Cold War Russia
feared this very scenario and America
had begun to develop sophisticated
anti-ballistic missile systems that
could detonate Russian missiles at
altitude way before they hit their
target Russia didn't like this so they
developed the ultimate weapon the
ultimate deterrence a world destroying
weapon that would leave no survivors the
doomsday machine the Soviet Union
created the largest bomb in history
nicknamed tsar bomba the king of bombs
it was tested in 1961 in the wilds of
Siberia
it had 1,600 times the combined power of
the bombs that were dropped on Hiroshima
and Nagasaki even the Soviets were
surprised by how immensely powerful the
blast truly was it destroyed an entire
nearby village flattening stone houses
and
shuttered windows a thousand miles away
in finland our norway but nikita
khrushchev wasn't satisfied it's no use
having the world's most powerful weapon
if nobody is left alive to use it so he
came up with a plan a real-life doomsday
device that dr. Strangelove will be
proud of the plan was to take a large
cargo ship and turn the entire vessel
into a nuclear bomb the entire cargo
hold will be filled with fissionable
radioactive material it will be many
many times more powerful than the Tsar
Bomba and truly powerful enough to
destroy the entire planet all on its own
it would permanently circle the
coastline of Russia and onboard sensors
would detect radiation levels if at any
point extremely high radiation was
detected indicating that Russia had been
hit with a nuclear weapon the ship would
automatically with no human intervention
detonate itself destroying the planet
it was completely automated and it would
ensure that even if no Russian was left
alive that they would still have the
last laugh by killing everything what a
truly terrifying prospect
luckily Russian scientists managed to
persuade Khrushchev to drop the idea it
never went ahead but another plan
did a real doomsday device that still
exists today dr. Strangelove may have
been fictional but the doomsday device
is very real and it's called Russia's
dead heart because even when Russia is
dead they can still play that huh the
system was codenamed
Perimeter thousands of sensors were
placed all around Russia
these sensors measured seismic activity
light levels radioactivity overpressure
and sound levels all this data is fed
back to underground computers and the
data is crumbs and if the data suggests
that Russia has been hit by a nuclear
blast
system automatically activates itself
once activated the dead hang system
sends a signal to every missile silo in
the country and they will automatically
and instantaneously fire at every major
city around the world for mostly America
absolutely no human interaction is
needed for the system to function this
seems pointless and totally excessive
but it serves a very important function
it is the only real deterrence that can
stop America from launching a preemptive
strike on Russia's nuclear facilities
and heads of government disabling their
retaliation abilities so in a twisted
way the world's most chilling device is
actually the only thing saving ghazan
what's the scariest part you would think
that such a system would have been
disabled or turned off at the end of the
Cold War but high-ranking Russian
insiders have reported that the system
is still fully functional and remains
activated today what Russia committed
the cardinal sin of a doomsday system
they forgot to tell anyone
Russia kept the existence of the dead
hand system top secret for years until a
high-ranking official linked knowledge
of it in the 90s and in the words of dr.
strange look the whole point of a
doomsday machine is love if you keep it
a secret
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please click here to support
me on patreon which helps to support the
channel and you can get some cool
rewards like early access to all my
videos click here to watch another video
and if you haven't already don't forget
to subscribe